في موازاه المصاعد الدبلوماسيه المستجده
لايجاد مخرج للحرب الاوكرانيه تتواصل
المعارك دون توقف على العديد من الجبهات
لكن هناك تحول رئيسي يلوح في الافق على
ارض الميدان يتمثل بتحول اوكرانيا من
الدفاع الى الهجوم هذا ما يشير اليه
مسؤولون موالون لروسيا فيخرسون فقد اتهموا
بالاستعداد للهجوم عبر نهر دينيبرو الحديث
نقله القائم باعمال محافظ القطاع المحافظ
المقاطعه عفوا التي اعلنت روسيا ضمها
والذي قال ان وحدات من الجيش الاوكراني
تقوم خفيه بنقل القوات والمعدات الحربيه
وتجميع الزوارق المائيه وذلك استعدادا
لمحاوله عبور النهر
وفي الاثناء تتاهب القوات الروسيه في
القرم لهجوم اوكراني وشيك في شبه الجزيره
بحسب مسؤول الروسي وفيما يجري الحديث عن
هجوم محتمل في خرسون والقرم شنت القوات
الاوكرانيه هجوما في مقاطعه دومياتك وذكرت
مصادر بالمقاطعه ان الجيش الروسي تصدى
لهجوم الاوكراني المعاكس باتجاه جنوب
المقاطعه المصدر ذاته اشار الى القضاء على
عدد من المقاتلين الاخرى
هذه التطورات تاتي لتزكي اخبارا اخرى تشير
الى انك تجهز نفسها للمبادره الى الهجوم
فخلال الاسبوع الماضي اشارت وكاله رويترز
الى ان اوكرانيا قامت باعداد وتجهيزه ثمان
وحدات اقتحام هجوميه اطلق عليها اسم الحرس
الهجومي ووفقا لزعيم مجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
فان هذه القوه قد تضم حوالي 200 الف
عسكريين
اما فيما يتعلق بالمعركه الابرز والاطول
معركه باخموت فان الزحف الروسيه لا يزال
متواصلا في اخر التطورات قال رئيس مجموعه
فاجنر ان قوته باتت تسيطر على اكثر من 80%
من المدينه من جهتها اوضحت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه او احداث من قوات الانزال الجوي
تقدم دعما لفصائل باجنر من اجل السيطره
على وسط المدينه مشيره الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه باتت تتواجد فقط في الجزء
الغربي منها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات